aleri une femme enceinte avec ben bière
qui va pas que de ça n'importe quel bien
c'est quoi bah voyez le nombre de biens
mais moi chérie je pense qu'elle a eu
six enfants
enfin les loups qui est will play il y à
une femme
voilà qui a eu après la centenaire guéri
du courant d'un virus un autre miracle a
eu lieu en france lady miracle
incroyable non mais c'est vrai je vous
le dis et je vous le dis elle a mis au
monde des sextuplés vous savez comme on
a de chances d'avoir des sèche cheveux
et une chance sur 4,7 milliards 4,1
chance sur 4 7 milliards ça s'est passé
à strasbourg fin de semaine dernière une
femme a donné naissance à six enfants
cinq filles et un garçon en exemple ce
pauvre évidemment tout le monde en a
parlé et regardé petit récapitulatif ça
c'est une info bah ça c'est des infos
que j'adore regarder oui il faut
rappeler à ce qu'on voit la photo il n'y
a pas besoin pour avoir un nom des cinq
super d'avoir 6 4 6 mètres monde si mou
des deux côtés en cette période les
bonnes nouvelles ne sont pas légion et
pourtant malgré la crise
djokovic 19 qui depuis trois mois semble
avoir englouti l'enthousiasmé général de
nombreuses femmes met au monde des
enfants des événements qui font du bien
surtout que ce n'est pas un seul enfant
qui est né jeudi dernier dans l'est de
la france ni deux ni trois mais six d'un
coup cette maman originaire de
strasbourg dans le bas-rhin accoucher au
chu de hautepierre de sextuplés un fait
rarissime et déjà vu en france il ya
plus de 30 ans au compteur 5 filles et
un garçon sont sortis de son ventre
avant d'être placé en soins intensifs
car tous considérés comme de grands
prématurés
si l'équipe médicale est confiante elle
reste tout de même prudente et annonce
de longs mois d'hospitalisation pour
réguler les carences des nouveau-nés et
gérer
situation un événement qui n'arrive que
lors d'un accouchement sur 4,7 milliards
olalala jean-michel mais jean michel
viens de postillonner mais c'est pas
passé s'est passé à san mamés lui
l'envoi des postillons je vous jure que
c'est vrai qu'il peut toucher un oiseau
dit c'est un truc de fou lui même temps
c'est pas parce qu'ils postienne ici
qu'il faut vous l'aviez les mains là bas
j'étais un spectateur jupe mais j'ai eu
très peur oui j'ai eu très peur allez
juste avant à prendre mais bon c'est une
jolie nouvelle si l'enfant est très
honnêtement moi ça m'arrive
six enfants je suis un peu on en voit
déjà avec à vous avez du mal à sortir
parce que c'est parce que c'est très
compliqué a choisi s'occupe pas
d'éduquer un enfant d'élever un
structure sis d'un coup en même temps là
whaou
je vous dis rabat c'est ce que disait
phil barney de façon à avoir un seul
enfant de toi c'est pas évident on
disait oui comme dit kenny un seul
garçon sur 100 m sur 6 merci on a la
télé par les sifi cinq filles les
intérêts